knock knock who's there who there me and
this can broccoli that I'm about to make
you eat No
I hate broccoli I hate everything about
broccoli
I hate broccoli my parents had to serve
me broccoli in a bunch of different ways
and at the end of the day as soon as
they left the room I would often just
throw it away whenever I go out to eat
with friends and I get broccoli on my
dish I always give it away to somebody
else I went on a date where a guy told
me he was gonna cook me dinner and it
was a nice steak which I loved and then
a huge side of broccoli which I hate do
I eat the broccoli and hope I don't
throw up or do I not eat the broccoli
and then I'm the 22 year old who still
won't eat her vegetables so I ended up
just pushing it around my plate never
saw him again so I just think there's no
way that anybody can make me like
broccoli
there is nothing any of these chefs can
do to get me to like broccoli it's been
tried it's not gonna happen I don't
think there is anything you could do to
make me like broccoli my name is Ross
Panetta currently the junior sous chef
over at pig and cow they're cooking
professionally for about three years now
I'm happy healthy latina aka chef yachty
aka the vegetable Slayer and I'm
bringing that plant-based natural
Caribbean flavor to all the cooking that
I do I think I've been cooking
professionally for about five years a
lot of the work that I do is actually
with children and so I'm constantly
having to hide and tuck vegetables and
blend them and deconstruct it and bring
it in some way I have to be a picky
eater since growing up I've got a lot of
allergies you kind of grow around it and
you learn how to switch the two things
with my experience with picky eaters
it's a little bit difficult sometimes
not gonna lie at the end of the day you
got to make everybody satisfied with
what you do and what you cook well y'all
picky eaters out there we try and meet
y'all come see us bring us our victim
rolling it down we're ready to make
believers we hear that you're one of
these people now that don't like
broccoli why is that I don't like the
taste I don't like the smell I don't
like the texture I don't like the color
I don't like the gag reflex it gives me
okay I think it's the texture mixture
just like the little fuzzy bits on the
top event larette's we learned something
new today I don't understand how you're
supposed to eat it
it confuses me do I eat the top do I eat
the bottom don't eat it all at the same
time our taste buds like change our
palates are up and change as we get
older I think you have this like scar
with broccoli but you may you may not
have lots of scars emotional scars hmm I
think the only times I've ever been
presented with broccoli it's just been
steamed and it's just not well this is
thought I'm always talking about it's
not that people don't like vegetables is
that they don't do the same things to
vegetables that they do let's say to
like protein seasoned it put sauces on
what are kind of things you do like to
eat spicy food like savory things are
your basis okay like savory like spicy I
dance when I'm happy yeah so like you're
saying things that I like so like savory
spicy you're gonna be in a situation
ship with broccoli today okay not a
relationship just a situation ship one
nice them thank you
oddly ever in your favor I think they're
gonna go from hating broccoli to at
least mildly liking it or possibly
loving it who knows what is going to
happen
I cannot wait to mix in Dominican and
Caribbean flavors into vegetables I
decided to go to chains on this broccoli
I'm gonna make it two ways and I'm gonna
deconstruct it first I'm gonna bring it
into a broccoli corn and black-eyed pea
fritter and then I'm going to do a
charred broccoli chimichurri sauce on
the bottom I don't think that they're
expecting some heat some spice some
savoriness I'm bringing sweet corn into
my fritters to balance out the broccoli
taste but my chimichurri has sofrito in
it which is a Dominican Caribbean green
spice blend so that's my kind of
different little take on it a little
trick on my Fuyu I'm going to be making
is it corn aioli with a chimichurri
[Music]
people are always like scared about the
flavor of broccoli the char adds flavor
and disguise the broccoli if you like
barbecue like anything charred you know
I think that introducing the corn with
the chimichurri will make it over the
top so much broccoli Matt broccoli right
Matt broccoli done they said they liked
spice they like herb enos they like
brightness so I got jalapeno to get all
up in your face I got some chopped
cilantro for the earthiness I'm coming
back with the zester so we've got some
broccoli corn fritters here over a
charred broccoli sofrito chimichurri
with jalapeno fresh cilantro and lemon
zest garnish we came to slay the
broccoli game so finally finished my
plate what we have here is a charred
broccoli charred corn aioli with the
sirloin and a try broken chimichurri on
top
[Music]
ready okay it's not that stronger brothy
taste at all there's a lot going on yeah
if it were not for the color I wouldn't
know that there was any like green
veggies in here I think that slight edge
is gonna go to the veggie dish I like
the spicy jalapenos going on this is
really hard just like both of them were
really good and they were both super
flavorful thought it was interesting
that both dishes also had corn I think
the corn masa the broccoli tastes really
well but I feel like I prefer the
appetizer dish or the steak dish
appetizer dish was had so many different
flavors and when I was biting into it
and I was thinking about how many
vegetables were in it I was just like so
shocked and steak dish was also great a
fact that it had like vegetables and and
broccoli on it but I liked the appetizer
dish dare I say do we have some broccoli
lovers a little bit about if it was did
you love the broccoli today are not
other broccoli lover per se but I'm a
believer now that you can make broccoli
taste good if you have some bomb-ass
professional chefs prepare it for you my
mom would be smiling really proudly
right now maybe crying so do you think
we slayed this challenge seam work make
the gene work baby slit
[Music]